Arby can you talk about your first-year
screenwriting yeah how was that for you
it was interesting I could tell you
about my first night screenwriting I you
know I had been around the film for a
long time so I wasn't I wasn't foreign
to the the formatting and to the concept
and everything and I had this what I
Clos was is most first-time
screenwriters do I had this brilliant
idea and I had this fantastic opening
and I said okay tonight's the night I'm
sitting down I cracked my final draft I
said you know I'm going and cracked a
bottle of Jack Daniels and pour myself a
drink and five hours later I had nine
pages and I was like not bad and my
protagonist had moved from his car to
the front door of a building and that
was nine pages and nobody else it was
the only character and I went yes should
I think I have a problem I think yeah I
think I got some troubles so that was my
first night but you know I kind of
rebounded quick and really really took
it upon myself to learn on my own didn't
depend on a lot of the so-called expert
screenwriting books that you know some
which I feel are you know promote the
obvious and just got myself back in it
and said okay I you know I'm not gonna
write a first draft that's 200 pages you
know I'm gonna write a first draft
that's 125 130 and get it down I'm gonna
know my story and the first script was
okay you know it actually got a pretty
good response I actually almost I
actually got an offer to write on a TV
staff wall fit but I didn't want I
didn't want it and it was a it was a it
wasn't exactly as great as it sounds it
was it was very very junior and very
very you know nobody knew if the show
was even going to go and everything but
it was interesting to get that kind of
response so I said well maybe it's not
too bad you know the second script I
wrote was also in the first year that
did really well it was a story that came
to me kind of quick and I spent a little
bit more time outlining it did I did the
first one so when I sat down to write it
I
really really knew where I wanted it to
go and I knew my ending I think this is
always imperative when you're a
screenwriter you know I knew my it's
okay to have that ending change and so
ready to have that journey along the way
but I think it's always great to really
know where you're going and I did with
this particular story that's scripted
really really well it was a
semi-finalists of the page and I think
it was a semifinalist at Austin that
year I think that was 2011 or 2012 and
then the third script is one of some
production in pretty well in development
right now with David so you've read all
the screenwriting books what we're maybe
you haven't but what are some of your
issues with them I'm just well I find
you know I don't want to name names you
know but there is one out there that has
a lot of really cute little names for
things that I feel like a very very
obvious to me screenwriting is if you
understand free act structure okay and a
lot of people don't like if you
understand the fact that you need to
have an inciting incident then you have
it FF first act break and a second act
break and you have high midpoint and you
know if you could understand these
concepts and those you know you might
have to read a book for that if you know
you're just starting out but if you can
understand those things then to me if
you understand those basic tenants of
writing a screenplay then to me
everything else you need to learn is
available to you by reading great
screenplays because you should be able
to at some point and maybe before you
have a write fade in for the first time
if you understand those concepts and you
understand you know story and general
arcs that you know all your characters
need to have arcs and you know things of
that nature at least you know first
secondary care you know I mean not every
character not the guy that's giving you
a lot of a ticket behind the counter but
if you understand the basics of that
then you should be able to look at a
really really good screenplay and be
able to identify why that screenplay
works here's the inciting incident
here's the first act break here's the
arc of this character here's you know
coming into a scene late and getting out
early you know I mean like all those
things that you you know you learn I
knew a lot of those things from working
as a producer not everybody does okay I
get that what I'm saying is is that I
feel like some of the more general
screenwriting books
there are more paint-by-numbers and you
don't want something that's
paint-by-numbers you know you wanted to
have room to roam when you're a
screenwriter and that means that if a
book is telling you the inciting
incident needs to be on page 12 that you
shouldn't be sitting there you know
ready to lose your mind because happens
on page 11 and you want to pet it so it
goes to the page you know you wanna give
somebody an extra how you doing I'm
doing good how you doing you know
dialogue to get yourself to page 12
that's why I don't like those books but
my education really came from reading
very very good screenplays I always tell
people I get to speak at a lot of
conferences and I say if you know the
general basics that I'm talking about
take a really really good screenplay and
go read it I take Raging Bull read it
okay and then put the DVD in and sit
down with the screenplay and the remote
and watch read along and watch why it
works and this is also a filmmaking
that's the class in a lot of ways too
because you get to understand why the
filmmaker
you know made the choices he did as well
but the purpose of the screenplay
screenwriting you know you look and you
figure out why everything works and it
also works by the way with bad
screenplays why did why didn't this work
why did this movie fail and you'll find
the same mistake she'll find the
dialogue went on too long the character
really doesn't have a not the main
character really doesn't have an arc you
know the second act goes on for two
hours you know it could be anything but
if you understand why it's not working
or why it does work I think it informs
you as a writer as to how to be more
concise how to write your characters
more vibrantly how to write good
dialogue I think all those things are
within really good screenplays I think
that's where the masterclass is once you
learn the basics
you